bras de fer entre la justice belge sur
le et la justice française sur le
dossier serge dassault bruxelles menace
de créer un incident diplomatique avec
paris si on ne lui fournit pas des
pièces relatives au dossier dans lequel
l'avionneur français est soupçonné de
corruption en belgique explications de
valérie fournis aux coups de colère de
la justice belge depuis deux ans que les
enquêteurs de liège réclame les
documents saisis au siège parisien d'une
des sociétés du groupe dassault paris
fait la sourde oreille et aujourd'hui
stéphane de clerck
le ministre belge de la justice menace
de créer un incident diplomatique avec
la france
cela a assez duré maintenant il faut que
les autorités françaises disent oui ou
non à la demande si c'est non et
inadmissible et cela mérite un incident
de la plus haute importance
les ennuis de serge dassault avec la
justice belge remonte à mai 96 le
parquet de liège les soupçonne d'avoir
versé en 89
plusieurs dizaines de millions de francs
en pots de vin au parti socialiste belge
francophone et flamand un mandat d'arrêt
international est alors lancé contre
serge dassault et la justice belge
réclament certains éléments de l'enquète
française l'ancien ministre jacques
toubon a toujours refusé motif sécurité
nationale elisabeth guigou elle a bien
rencontré stéphane declerck il ya une
semaine à prague sa réponse tarde
toujours
pourtant au salon du bourget samedi
dernier le ciel judiciaire entre paris
et bruxelles semblait s'éclaircir avec
la levée du mandat d'arrêt international
est-ce qu'en contrepartie de ce geste de
bonne volonté vous allez répondre aux
convocations du juge d'instruction à
bruxelles s'il ne soit élu après ce
qu'il me demande plus précisément donc
si vous êtes convoqué vous irez et bien
cela dépendra des conditions mais pour
moi et ne m'a rien demandé
en tout cas c'est lui qui a décidé de
lever ce mandat et c'est très bien
cette affaire empoisonne les relations
entre paris et bruxelles depuis plus de
deux ans
bruxelles qui attend toujours une
réponse de la justice française olivier
folle n'occupe plus le poste de
directeur de la police judiciaire
parisienne
il a été démis de ses fonctions et
remplacé par patrick riou les deux
décrets viennent de paraître au journal
officiel
olivier folle a réagi ce matin pour la
première fois cette mutation demandé par
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
mathieu chez olivier folle s'en va le
directeur de la police judiciaire
devenue pour la nouvelle majorité
le symbole de l'état rpr vient d'être
muté il est nommé inspecteur général
par décret du président de la république
vous prenez comme une mutation sanction
non je ne vous le dire je pars sans état
d'âme les eaux et posent nos
fonctionnaires tels que celui directeur
régional de la police judiciaire sont
encore une fois à la disposition du
pouvoir exécutif donc je ne prends ça ni
comme il fonctionne autrement sans état
d'âme quand je ne vous le dira en juin
96 olivier folle avait interdit à ses
hommes d'assister le juge halphen lors
de sa perquisition au domicile des époux
tiberi
soutenu par son ministre de l'intérieur
jean louis debré lionel jospin avait à
l'époque demandé qu'il soit démis de ses
fonctions je ferai aucun commentaire sur
la sphère qui était d'ailleurs
longuement explicite et encore une fois
à travers les médias je me rendrai
absolument aucune polémique aujourd'hui
et donc je ne viens pas faire plus de
commentaires à l'occasion mon départ son
successeur est déjà connu
patrick riou ancien patron de la brigade
criminelle réputé pour son impartialité
il a aujourd'hui une priorité renouer le
dialogue avec les magistrats après
laffaire tiberi il achèterait que dans
six mois mais d'ores et déjà nous
connaissons le montant de la facture le
prix moyen de la vignette 81,18 sera en
hausse d'un pour cent à 520 francs pour
les voitures les plus répandus vous le
voyez ici